bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 du
week-end l'émission dédiée à vos loisirs
et surtout culturel de cette fin de
semaine au sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
la fête de la ville à montigny le
bretonneux ville qui vous propose de
relever 30 défi ce sera dimanche et
nabucco de verdi en plein air ce sera
samedi abus qu'il y aura aussi des idées
sportif pour ce week-end et le coup de
coeur ciné de la semaine et on commence
tout de suite avec la fête de la ville à
montigny le bretonneux une journée
festive donc est organisé dimanche pour
relever le challenge tous ensemble c'est
réservé aux minimes ont peint mais pas
seulement et pour en parler avec nous
marie toussaint bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller municipal délégué à
l'événementiel donc à la mairie de
montigny je les dis c'est une opération
il ya trente défis qui vont être à
relever par les animaux temps et pas
seulement
tout à fait de quoi s'agit-il donc toute
personne présente sur le site de parc
des sports de la couldre est invité à
participer à ce challenge
donc pour participer à ce challenge elle
devrait représenter le quartier de son
choix
alors il faut savoir que la ville est
donc divisée en 8 quartiers et le but
c'est de relever un challenge pour son
quartier préféré alors soit le quartier
où on habite
soit un quartier qu'on a envie de
représenter le quartier de coeur que
vous choisirez donc pour participer à ce
challenge nous avons choisi de
d'identifier chaque quartier par un
bracelet de couleur ainsi qu'une carte
de 25 points
chaque carte complété par les défis les
30 défis qui seront proposées par les
services des sports service culture et
service jeunesse ainsi que les
associations présentes
donc chaque défilé concrétiser réaliser
rapportera 1 point la carte de 25 points
complètent donne droit à une balade qui
sera mise dans une vasque à cet effet
donc là la vaste que représentant le
quartier pour lequel vous avez souhaité
concourir et à l'issue de la journée on
regardera
la vasque qui aura le plus de talent qui
aura le plus et de bas leur travail
chaque jour à la durantaye d'ex-aequo
tout à fait rien il ya un règlement pour
les ex-aequo voilà donc on
comptabilisera toutes les cartes de
chaque quartier et à l'issue de cette
comptabilité on aura trouvé un gagnant
pour cinq ans donc j'ai dit plus de 30
challenge à relever au parc des sports
de la couldre ce sera donc ce dimanche
entre 11 heures et 18 heures il ya quoi
comme challenge par exemple on peut
relever parce que vous avez dit les
associations effectivement il partit
slave et donc nous avons des
associations culturelles stilbestrol
inscrits secrètes les dames les dames
noir les échecs dans les sports par
exemple nous avons le golf le tennis de
table tennis le foot le rugby les
il y en a encore plein de jeunes encore
l'arc en gros faut être bon un peu
partout vingt-deux associations
sportives seront présentes six
associations culturelles
nous avons également le service jeunesse
qui nous fait aussi qui aura des
animations sur place
c'était le catal put efficace qui seront
proposés tout à fait donc durant toute
là toute la journée nous aurons la
chorale à une chorale qui viendra nous
faire un une prestation
il y aura également l'école de musique
du manet et à l'issue de la soirée à 19
heures après la remise du challenge pour
le quartier gagnante qui sera remise par
monsieur le maire monsieur michel vigier
donc à l'issue de ce challenge nous
aurons un spectacle par alpha projette
donc c'est vraiment une journée très
complète voilà bleus 11 heures à 22
heures à 22 heures mais pour les défis
ces 11 heures à 18 heures c'était
important de dire que c'est gratuit
c'est gratuite les qu'on peut vraiment
tous participé alors les ongles longs
teints et viandes sont invités à
participer pour représenter leurs cadets
mais si vous n'êtes pas fini mon teint
vous pouvez aussi participer pour
soutenir le quartier de votre choix de
votre coeur ou un quartier vous aviez
anciennement habité par exemple sais pas
il n'y a pas de souci c'est vraiment
ouvert à tous ça c'est important de le
mentionner
le but c'est vraiment de faire quoi de
la cohésion entre les quartiers où
permettre aussi aux associations de se
rencontrer emprunte un fait donc ça
permet aussi donc de se rencontrer par
par quartier et les autres quartiers de
la ville sachant que nous avons ouï
quartier de découvrir les associations
parce que il ya beaucoup d'activités
proposées et ça permet de découvrir les
assos les
les différentes associations que de la
ville nous aurons également la
possibilité de se retrouver en famille
c'est complètement ludique
nous avons également j'ai oublié de vous
le dire dix structures gonflables style
intervilles et je pense que ça plaira
aux personnes c'est clair aux moins
jeunes pour les tout petits nous avons
pensé aussi à eux et on aura une pêche à
la ligne
tu as donc des oies deux ans vous pouvez
pas vous pouvez participer à ce
challenge
merci beaucoup par exemple est revenue
sur le poste de 7,8 ce week-end donc je
rappelle la fête de la ville à mon team
brawn
on l'aura compris c'est pour les animaux
nains mais pas seulement et c'est
surtout pour toute la famille à partir
de tout petits pour la pêche à la ligne
et 18 mois mais tout à fait c'est
vraiment dès l'âge de 2 ans pouvait
venir participer à la fête de la ville
ce sera ton groupe ce dimanche pour les
défis à relever de 11h à 18h au parc des
sports de la kul et c'est gratuit merci
mr ou marie la toussaint est revenu sur
plateau à l'est une fête de la ville en
cache une autre
retour sur la fête de la ville de
trappes c'était le week-end dernier
thierry corps et biens domaniaux hélas
apple décide c'est là bas qu'il soit
commentryens sénégalais bien marocains
c'est là où tu un point en commun ils
mettent l'eau à la bouche la diversité
était le seul mot d'ordre samedi dernier
à trappes pour la fête de la ville les
habitants étaient invités à se retrouver
à travers une journée ponctuée de
concerts et d'animations autour genre
bonne journée aujourd'hui c'est le
deuxième jour du ramadan mais quand même
c'est préparer à manger chez moi et je
suis bien avec les enfants la fête voilà
a fêté chaque année et on est capable
d'être ici de nombreuses activités
réparties sur plusieurs lieux faire une
partie de baby-foot au gymnase rousseau
ou bien profiter d'un concert au stade
gravaud il y en avait pour tous les
goûts
les aujourd'hui place ou cru local c'est
très important justement de de faire
vivre ce vivier artistes et qu'on
attrape l'exception qu'on fait cette
année c'est d'offrir à un groupe qui
sera élu vainqueur de ce petit crochet
l'enregistrement des titres dc groupe
les voilà qu rnb au reggae en passant
évidemment par le rap la musique à des
prix de l'avant sur sa fête pour venir
ici à part au public
c'est c'est un bonheur et
nous pressons venu pour moi aide pour
d'autres ça m'a fait plaisir
une bonne ambiance mais qui a tout ce
qu'il faut et ça fait plaisir que la vie
des draps de change pour mixer à c'est
la consécration il repartira vainqueur
de ce concours et pour finir la journée
rien de mieux que d'écouter des
professionnels pour l'occasion le groupe
sinsemilia était venu clôturer la soirée
un avant-goût la veille de la fête de la
musique
et on poursuit 7,8 week-end on va parler
opéra on va parler du nabucco de verdi
qui sera jouée en plein air ce samedi
soir dans le parc du château de buc et
en parle pour en parler avec nous
jean-marc le rudulier bonsoir vous êtes
le maire de la commune de but que vous
êtes l'initiateur de ces opéras en plein
air jeudi ses opéras parce que c'est la
neuvième et édition il ya du beau temps
est annoncé pour samedi pour écouter
donc le nabucco de verdi
d'abord pourquoi le nabucco de verdi pas
parce que déjà on a en a et écumé toutes
les toutes les toutes les autres opéras
on a fait l'écart mais on a fait carmen
on a fait ça très bien tu n'as fait
haïdara fait othello on a fait un
certain nombre de choses donc et l'année
prochaine on se prépare à faire un opéra
pour les 10 ans madame butterfly donc
cette année c'est bien les grands
classiques 1 dans l'opéra on a les seins
classes populaires dans le bon sens du
terme
pas celui qui a remporté le plus de
succès je crois que ça a été
carmen en a beaucoup c'est quand même
très connu parlez-nous justement de cet
opéra il a été créé en 1842 à la scala
de milan il a une belle histoire cet
opéra parce que en gros c'était le père
de la dernière chance pour verdi j'ai
envie mais là il a une belle histoire
parce qu'effectivement c'est l'opéra de
la dernière chance rue verdi parce que
il voulait être totalement abandonnés
ils avaient décidé d'abandonner
et puis
il a été convaincu qu'il fallait qu'il
écrive un dernier opéra il y a il a
réécrit nabucco et là effectivement ça a
été le succès la vraie renaissance de
verdi parce qu'il avait perdu sa famille
la veille à leur enfance et sa dernière
oeuvre était un vrai échec
en gros voilà il est reparti je vous
propose maintenant des écouteurs pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas je ne sais
pas mais on a beaucoup dit ce que je me
repose écoutez un extrait de cet opéra
m
voilà un petit air donc je pense que
tout le monde aura bien reconnu a eu le
kers et c'est donc le nabucco de verdi
dans le parc du château de buc c'est
mené par la troupe opéra classique alors
un mot sur cette compagnie annonce élue
compagnie allemande qui est dirigée par
michael vaccaro et qui à me qui a
encadré les les neuf opéras que qu'on a
déjà présenté donc c'est vrai que on a
découvert parce que nous avons dû qu'un
partenariat avec une ville allemande qui
bat chaque bar et un jour le maire de
bat cheval barres en 2006 nous a invités
dans un château le château de braunfels
à assister à la représentation de la
tosca et alors là vraiment moi sa main
emballé si vous voulez y chercher un
lieu en région parisienne pour faire la
dino on a un château il est venu voir il
est tombé amoureux du château et depuis
ce temps là et bien voilà c'est ça s'est
passé comme ça alors cette année c'est
avec l' orchestre du théâtre national de
constanta en roumanie et c'est sous la
direction de deux
d'un chef d'orchestre allemand hans ars
combien de chanteurs combien de
musiciens à peu près alors les musiciens
il y en a il y en a bien il y en a une
quarantaine cinquantaine même les
chanteurs alors là comme il ya les
coeurs alors en plus on a fait
intervenir des enfants des écoles
puisque l'opéra on essaye en même temps
d'avoir une formation vers les écoles
donc cette année on a le la
participation d'une école qui est lui
clément qui a déjà participé depuis
trois années à ses opéras en tant que
figurants bien sûr mais il les enfants
adorent ça donc on a une classe de cp
une classe de cm2 et pour la première
fois cette année on a une classe du
lycée franco-allemand une classe de 6e
soit d'hirson leurs professeurs qui vont
participer au coeur de verdi donc c'est
l'accent de kerdrel est également
pédagogique
c'est une action pédagogique n en
retournant l'opéra ce que toujours un
peu compliqué cette comprendre est ce
que est ce que ce sera alors la santé et
aytré et cette année on a pris nous une
nouvelle une nouvelle solution qui
devrait porter tous de bons résultats de
très bons soleil dernière c'est vrai
parce que si vous voulez on est on est
au mois de juin c'est les journées les
plus longues
ça commence à 21h et il fait vraiment
noir à 22h30 22h45
donc là mais voilà où vous pourrez nous
dire qu'on pourra bien le dire d sutil à
bien lire des soutes est ce que des
moyens techniques qui sont mis en oeuvre
particulier parce que c'est un opéra qui
est en plein air donc c'est à la fois
très très chouette pour le public de
voir ça en plein air mais au niveau
qualité sonore ça peut leur qualité
sonore c'est vrai que les les solistes
ont des micros sur le sur eux et c'est
vrai que depuis qu'on va peut-être pas
la première année effectivement mais
après effectivement michael vaccaro
avait avait décidé de médecins et depuis
qu'on a mis ce matériel en place de
toutes parts dont on entendait on
pire et on entend très bien de toute
part parce qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
pouvait accueillir beaucoup de monde je
crois que madame vous avez vendu 1000
places n'a déjà vous aimez les gens ce
dernier 320 à 1316 vraie place et je
pense j'ai dit je pense que cette année
on fera ça sera complet ça sera complet
donc le nabucco à de verdi c'est à
samedi à partir de 21h au théâtre
pardon dans le parc du château de l'âme
de buc château de buc voilà c'est l'état
rex ont entre 20 et 35 euros
j'en profite puisque j'ai un maire en
plateau pour lui évidemment lui poser la
question sur le financement
on sait que les villes connaissent des
baisses de dotations de l'état et c'est
parfois un peu compliqué vous haut
niveau par exemple votre politique
culturelle est ce que vous avez dû
revoir certaines choses à la baisse ou
la finalement votre père à idées non
nous nous pour l'instant tant que c'est
vrai qu'il ya des baisses de dotations
mais nous avons décidé de privilégier
d'aidé comme la culture si vous voulez
on a décidé de la privilégiez donc les
grands événements culturels que nous
rajoute reste et on doit rester alors on
fait appel maintenant à des sponsors
c'est sûr on a cette année un
financement sans pourfend municipal
l'agglomération versailles grand parc à
laquelle adhèrent 500% pas tout à fait
100% pas il ya une plus une subvention
qui nous vient du conseil régional d'île
de france
une petite subvention qui nous vient du
conseil départemental et puis un petit
peu de notre agglomération
le reste la totalité est assuré par la
ville et ça continue est certes rassuré
quant à sa merci vous confiant marque le
regard des revenus soit un taux de 7,8
ce week-end nous parlait donc de nabucco
de verdi qui sera jouée en plein air
donc ce samedi à partir de la vingtaine
hier dans le parc du château de buc
merci beaucoup
on va continuer on va rester en domaine
musical 240 enfants de l'agglomération
de trappes et l'encours et montigny se
sont produits sur la scène du théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ils ont interprété un opéra alors non
pas le nabucco de verdi mais ancelle et
gretel d'après un conte de grimm huit
mois de travail pour réaliser cette
performance des images signées maxime le
maine
à
il y a huit - certains n'avaient jamais
chanté en moins d'une année ses élèves
de trappes d'elancourt ou de montigny se
retrouvent sur la scène du théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il interprète un opéra rien que cela
hansel et gretel
au début c'est difficile parce qu'ils
savent rien ils n'ont pas l'habitude de
chanter ils savent pas respirer savent
pas se tenir
ils arrivent à se concentrer
suffisamment moi je demande 50 minutes
de concentration et et voilà il ya prés
salés parle petit à petit ils ont dans
le projet commence à comprendre
l'histoire on fait des chansons fait des
jeux il faut qu'il nous dit qu'il faut
être très patient et il faut lui les
enfants et après ça marche
gavrila nous apprenez à être droit à
écouter a bien chanté
et surtout ils sont peut être bien
j'ai ressenti énormément de joie on
était tous heureux tu me fais appeler
tout le monde a applaudi après c'est
magnifique
m
une année de travail donc avec la
maîtrise de trappes et des solistes
professionnels très très lourd mais je
crois la mission accomplie parce qu'en
fait c'est on peut faire vraiment un
travail on veut les pousser les enfants
le plus loin possible
là nous avons 70 % d'enfants de
quartiers prioritaires et quartier de
trades d'elancourt est en fait ils
s'investissent énormément dans le rôle
de la vilaine sorcière qui capture les
deux enfants maureen dor comédienne
belge
elle s'est dite totalement emballé par
le projet l'opéra c'est pas la culture
non plus de plein de gens
donc c'est ça qui est merveilleux c'est
d'une ambition total c'est ça
l'intégration l'intégration c'est exact
ça me fait rire on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut ya une semaine
l'intégration c'est de prendre des
enfants dans des écoles des enfants non
c'est pas la culture
le père à ancelle et gretel et c'est le
chant classique et tout le monde va me
revoir
et nous poursuivons ce magazine avec le
coup de coeur ciné de la semaine il est
signé galles pineau du grenier à sel de
trappes
bonjour cette semaine notre coup de
coeur au grenier à sel c'est le film
naruto the last pour la première fois
naoto arrive sur grand écran en france
c'est la conclusion de la saga ça fait
quinze ans que naruto et sur le petit
écran à la télé et donc pour l'épisode
final pour la fin de l'histoire de
naruto
vous pouvez retrouver au cinéma c'est un
film que l'on propose en version
française
ils durent une heure 52 donc je vous
dévoile pas là l'histoire est la suite
pour les fans connaissent tous et pour
les néophytes vous pouvez très bien
découvrir aussi cet épisode ultime qui
pourra peut-être vous donner envie de
voir là la fabuleuse saga
comment
il sera proposé pendant la fête du
cinéma notamment qui commence dimanche
28 juin pour aller jusqu au mercredi
suivant le 1er juillet donc vous
retrouverez évidemment naruto sur notre
site internet il y a aussi un
questionnaire avec un raid lots à gagner
un quiz n'hésitez pas à aller faire un
tour au type donc www.cineagde.com et
vous quels sont vos coups de coeur ou
vos coups de gueule de la semaine ce
sont les avis et de spectateurs au micro
d' elodie moines épauler cette semaine
par un à gimenez excellent un film
extrêmement subtile aider vraiment des
acteurs qui jouent merveilleusement bien
et tout est fait dans la finesse
vraiment c'est plus plaisant de ceux qui
ont les deux dans la salle et c'est un
tel plaisir très subtil on l'excusera
niveau presque nouveau par la crise
d'honneur toujours entre ces femmes mais
ce n'est jamais de vagues crise est là
cela tombe très subtil c'est par petites
touches impressionnistes titre est drôle
c'est bien c'est fin c'est assez subtil
sommes assez bons en fait c'est un peu
trop long et si bien joué mais voilà
très bien c'est une comédie française
sympathique dans lesquels françois
cluzet est tout à fait dans son rôle
super film c'était le prolongement de la
syrie dont enfin pour ceux qui ont vu la
série
c'était un super film était génial il
avait une bonne ambiance
past parfait en fait certainement
exister entre potes et ceux qui pour
ceux qui ont vu la série c'est la suite
le final quoi
et puis une dernière info cinéma c'est
la 31e fête du cinéma ce du 28 juin au
1er juillet les places sont toutes à 4
euros dans toutes les salles c'est
vraiment l'occasion d'en profiter
et maintenant pour continuer sa 7,8 sous
quel jeu propose maintenant de jeter un
coup d'oeil sur les rendez vous sports
dès cette fin de semaine
et on commence par du tennis de table
c'est un plaisir une centaine de joueurs
âgés de 10 à 60 ans va s'affronter au
gymnase et ken donc un plaisir le
tournoi permettra de clôturer de la
saison mais surtout de récolter des dons
pour développer le tennis de table au
togo et l'équipe nationale de ce pays
africain sera d'ailleurs présente pour
cet événement le tournoi est programmé
dimanche de 9h30 à 18h et les cérémonies
protocolaires et oui les cérémonies
protocolaires elles sont organisées à
partir de 16h30
les arts martiaux également à l'honneur
ce week-end la vie de guyancourt accueil
open des idées en taekwondo de 7h30 à
20h au gymnase de l'aviation c'est un
martial d'origine sud coréenne est très
impressionnant les sportifs peuvent en
effet utiliser leurs pieds et leurs
points pour combattre et si vous voulez
assister à cette manifestation
l'entrée est libre et puis un sport dont
on ne parle pas souvent mais qui d'après
ce qu'on va dire beaucoup la cote auprès
des jeunes aujourd'hui toujours à
guyancourt il y aura de la pétanque au
centre sportif les trois mousquetaires
un concours ouvert à tous organisé pour
fêter la fin de l'année le niveau risque
de risque d'être élevée les meilleurs
joueurs du département seront présents
pour ce rendez vous et les parties sont
programmés entre 13 heures et 22 heures
et pour finir ce 7,8 week-end je propose
maintenant une page exposition
et avant de nous quitter nous partons du
côté de la commanderie templiers à
elancourt pour une exposition consacrée
aux paysages proposée par jean françois
andré
jean-françois au green ne travaille pas
sur ce qu'il voit dans le réel ou à
travers des photographies
il invente ses paysages pour mieux
comprendre son travail
oriane prévost médiatrice culturelle
nous a servi de guide qu'ils
représentent des paysages qui sont
inventés mais dans chacun de ses
paysages et bien on peut trouver la
trace de l'activité humaine
alors on va jamais trouvé d'êtres
humains l'être humain n'est pas
représentée mais à chaque fois vous avez
vraiment la trace les stigmates de
l'activité humaine vous allez avoir des
troncs des routes des creusets les
avoirs des talus on voit qu'il ya eu
quelque chose peut-être un paysage post
industrielle ou alors paysages agricoles
ou d'android et carrière peut être enfin
en fait on voit vraiment ces traces de
l'activité humaine
une volonté de sa part de travailler sur
le noir et blanc ont véritablement il a
voulu faire cet exercice mettre en avant
le noir et blanc s'exercer à ce travail
peut-être aussi on peut faire une
comparaison avec la photographie
j'aperçois en regardant bien les oeuvres
que finalement il est de la couleur il
ya des taches de couleurs qui ressortent
et en s'approchant on voit véritablement
qu'il n'y a pas du tout que du noir et
blanc il ya du bleu du violet du orange
du verre mais effectivement c'est ce
nous pas de forcément des couleurs très
vives et c'est un petit peu dit soudan
dans le tableau
on se rend compte en fonction du point
donc on regarde le tableau d'où on
regarde le tableau que certaines choses
peuvent sembler très structuré très
précise et quand on s'en approche
et bien finalement tout est fou donc une
tâche qui de loin peut faire penser à un
arbre dès qu'on s'approche un petit peu
mais même sans être à 10 cm en étant à
50 voire 1 mètre
et bien finalement ça devient qu'une
tache parmi d'autres
une notion de figuratif et abstrait dans
le travail plastique ou jean-françois
oudry veut montrer le paysage tel qu'il
imagine avec une hotte toujours de
poésie à découvrir jusqu'au 5 juillet
cette édition est maintenant terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite
un excellent week end très bientôt